I'm getting married there's gonna be
hundreds of wedding guests huge plates
of vide ani tenet hands and a handsome
groom but this is my wedding my weddings
not for another six months and before
the auntie's picked me apart I'm trying
to figure out how to do things right you
see the arranged marriages of our
parents generation look really different
than relationships now and weddings
aren't just a party they set the tone
for what our futures look like as
hyphenated Americans hi I'm Serena I'm
Indian American and this is my fiancee
Saheb he's also Indian American we're in
the middle of planning our traditional
Indian wedding here in the US and when I
say traditional Indian I should say
Muslim because in India they're Hindus
Muslims six and more and they all have
different wedding traditions which are
intensely debated making the wrong call
could lead to family boycotting your
wedding day it's complicated first point
of contention the dress this is my
little sister Yasin today she's helping
me shop for my wedding dress so this
would be really nice for your Sankey
thumb or your henna there are so many
dress options for brides these days I
could wear a traditionally red langa
like this a super modern fusion one like
this or something in between
I do you think of this whoo it's pretty
from the front like in the back Oh what
would mom say if I wear this she
wouldn't let you here I think if I were
a Hindu or a Sikh bride I could totally
rock this mm-hmm
but for a Muslim bride it would just be
too scandalous would you ever want to
wear something like this as a right
thing as a bride I don't really want to
be a bride how come
I don't really believe in marriage I
think that there's just so much pressure
on like of course you're gonna get
married and we'll find the person to
like be this placeholder and I just
don't see that for myself
weddings are such an insane like
capitalist industry you could take that
money and be like part of a way to a
down payment on a house yes and if you
don't get married you'd be the first
woman in our family to opt out of
marriage intentionally that's pretty
cool
that's super goal isn't it's liquid what
is that open up for my life my sister
has a point but getting married it's at
the core of my Indian identity before me
almost all the marriages and my extended
family have been arranged the aunties
would get together and swap details on
wedding resumes to find the right match
someone with the same religion language
and status but I never wanted an
arranged marriage my fiance and I have
what's called a love match which means
we found each other without involving
our parents and we waited until we were
in our thirties to get married which is
really old in Indian standards and just
because our families are both Indian
doesn't mean they have anything in
common they don't even speak the same
language yeah like mine they speak
Gujarati
gam-cho in mine speaks or do I don't
understand a word of what your family
says and it only gets more complicated
if you marry outside the culture enter
Jessica and Hardeep her family is German
and Christian his family is Punjabi and
Sikh we both met each other on the
online game World of Warcraft and we met
each other killing monsters he would
send something in Punjabi and I'd have
to translate it oh wow and then I'd send
something in German and then he'd have
to translate that Jessica and her deep
kept their relationship secret from his
parents for nine years I'm the first in
my family to marry someone who is not
busy and that's a big deal it's a big
deal who did your parents want you to
marry
so my parents wanted and perfect
scenario would be someone Basie
from Punjab who seek a speaks Punjabi
and is familiar with all the traditions
and you brought home it was definitely
difficult to be the secret I had told
him numerous times over and over again
you need to tell them and he's like I
don't wanna be kicked down I don't want
to lose them I mean I couldn't totally
understand that
I feel looking back at 1940s 1950s you
didn't even see who you married your
parents just went over to another
parents house they talked to each other
and you were engaged and you didn't even
see your bride or the groom me I'm just
completely doubtful either back here
I've I've decided everything when he
finally got the courage to tell his
parents about Jessica things got so
heated that they stopped talking for a
while my dad was fine with it right away
but my mom she's more traditional and
she was more stuck on oh you should
marry a desi girl but eventually she
came around I can understand Jessica and
her deep situation because my older
sister Yazzie also married outside the
culture they tell me about some of the
traditions that you grappled with when
you are wedding planning well I really
wanted to make sure that the ceremony
reflected us as a couple that our
partnership is a partnership and it's an
egalitarian partnership so for example
we had a woman officiate our nikka which
was a big deal which was a big deal
in Muslim weddings Lina Kai's when we
signed the Islamic marriage contract in
sikh weddings couples circle the holy
book four times to get married and
during Hindu weddings they take seven
steps around the ceremonial fire modesty
is so important even in Bollywood movies
for the longest time there was never
ever kissing and like the couple's faces
are so close together but they would
never kiss during the wedding ceremony
we did not we we walked out
and we had a private moment to ourselves
and our first kiss was right there I'm
struggling with that it does feel like a
loss to me
how come I've been watching movies for
30 years where after you seal your union
you kiss to me getting the stand up in
front of like all our friends and family
was the ceiling our union I'm not sure
if we're gonna kiss on our wedding but I
really want to do something that so
happen I really want to have it's
dancing but dancing can be a bit of a
taboo in our community so why is that
[Music]
would it make you uncomfortable if we
pulled you onto the dance floor what
about if we pulled I mean John and Bob
on the dance floor what my mom is saying
is that you probably wouldn't see this
at a DC Muslim wedding but this is
Jessica and her deep sweating and
Punjabis are known for dancing so hebbs
parents by the way also have
reservations about dancing at our
wedding
yeah I got married and I'm neck so of
course all eyes are gonna point to
Yassin what are your thoughts on Yesi
not wanting to get married so if I don't
change my mind
I will keep reading we'll see who wins
but mom that's kind of interesting
because you are a divorced and you and
dad your marriage didn't work out and
you're so happy being a single you know
independent person so why is marriage so
important for a scene if we've seen that
the marriage can be quite flawed even my
grandpa who we call Baba is trying to
change our scenes mind she's not
convinced so you think I'll change my
mind Oh what if I don't change my mind
there's one more thing I haven't talked
to him about yet come a hair it's a
Muslim marriage tradition of a cash gift
the groom gives the bride it's the
opposite of a dowry which the bride's
family pays the groom and is common in
Hindu weddings on Jessica and her deeps
wedding day we saw something lighter her
deep was blocked from entering the
Gurudwara until he paid Jessica's family
to step aside I'm really nervous to talk
to you about than my hair because it
feels totally anti-feminist to choose a
number negotiate that number and then
like expect my partner to pay for it and
it just seems really old-school no I
think you get to use it like you can
that's your money you had to use it like
the next day if you wanted to have you
heard that there is a number that is the
traditional number to give us on my hair
yeah it was so there's a way to
calculate what that my hair would be in
today's terms what's the equivalent in
the present-day Scroll scroll Scroll in
dollars it is approximately three
hundred ninety six dollars and seventy
cents
and then it ends with and ela knows best
a letõs vests who knows the vest is I
think it would be helpful to understand
the process if you talk to my mom my
sisters or my dad yeah are your dad hi
dad
sound like um how you doing so pop up I
have some questions about my hair
why is that important what would the
minimum be I don't know that sounds like
a lot dad I feel like I'm earning so why
would I ask for so much money
ten thousand is reasonable in your
opinion used car okay pops well thanks
for your advice as I'm making decisions
about our wedding
I now realize that it's okay to switch
things up culture evolves and our
perspectives will too on our wedding day
so have been I will be reinventing
Indian traditions to fit our American
lives even if it doesn't please the
aunties oh and back to that whole
kissing thing cool so we're doing it
sure yes really yeah if you want to kiss
at the wedding we go kiss at the way
hey do
thanks for watching our video on Indian
weddings let me know what conversations
you're having about tying the knot we're
not tying the knot don't forget to
subscribe and let us know what untold
story is to cover next